Let's now go for a systematic reproduction process.
First we need to reproduce the environment in which the bug occurs.
Second we need to reproduce the steps required
to reproduce the problem.
Both of these can be abstracted to input.
All your program does is dependent on its input.
Therefore, if you can reproduce the input,
you can also reproduce the execution.
With that we already solved the problem.
Programs are nothing but mathematical functions.
If they have the same input, they will reproduce the same output, right?
Why is there actually a problem of reproducing?
That's the difference between theory and practice.
In theory, there is no difference.
In practice, there is, at least that's the theory.
Indeed, in practice the concept of what makes input to a program
is very variable.
We distinguish a number of typical inputs,
each coming up with its own issues.
We do have static data, user interaction, time of day or general time,
randomness, that is randomness on purpose.
We have the operating environment.
We have schedules, in particular for parallel programs.
We have physical influences, and we do have debugging tools.
All of these constitute input to the program,
and each of these brings up its own issues
as it comes to reproducing failures.
Let's start with regular static data.
In a batch-oriented program, these are the inputs that is the files of documents
your program processes.
Static data is the easiest to reproduce, because it can be
handled as an individual entity outside of your program.
If your program operates on files, all you need to do is to ship the data files.
If it works on a database, then use tables instead.
This includes all data that is under the control of the user.
If it's under your control, you probably already know it.
So, you care about the variable stuff.
For one thing, these are documents under the user's control
as well as configuration files, in which user's store their preferences
or the settings for they system at hand.
Obviously, if you have all the documents and the configuration files
that your program operates upon,
then it's fairly easy to reproduce the exact problem.
However, there's a small catch with that--just a tiny, tiny catch.
This tiny, tiny catch can become a big issue.
Let me illustrate this with an example.
Here again we have our remove html markup function,
and here comes an input as one could find it in, say, a user's document.
We can run the whole thing with this input
and very easily reproduce the failure.
In this case, the failing assertion.